the teams better perform the rustlers
going to be a massive and very nasty
riot I just came off the show floor at
the game developers conference after
checking out blood bowl too and I have a
confession to make I hate watching
sports I have another confession to make
I used to play a lot of Warhammer 40k
and have a largely unpainted elder army
collecting dust in my closet so if any
titles going to convince me to combine
my old pastime with something I don't
particularly like it's going to have to
be pretty novel with a 15-hour story
campaign eight unique races a large
helping of fantasy and plenty of combat
shenanigans and a little bit of referee
corruption blood bowl to just might pull
me in the next iteration of blood bowl
corrects a lot of the negatives of the
first game it has online league play it
has customization it eases players into
the rules and the visual look and feel
is considerably better blood bowl too
also includes modes friendly match for
one-off games managed where you can buy
and sell players with gold and cable TV
which allows you to save and watch
around 200 of your previous matches on
PC and around 50 on console players will
find many of their favorite races human
dwarf skaven orc chaos Dark Elf high elf
and the new feudal human team brittanya
they really do hate peasants game
playing the demo was a mix of turn-based
strategy dice rolls and
behind-the-scenes luck if a ref sees you
say beat up and down player mmm dirty
blood bowl too will also include a
persistent world in which when players
die they die and customizable stadiums
that grow as you succeed the Warhammer
universe still feels like a pretty
untapped IP in gaming blood bowl is one
of the more zany directions but in my
mind any war hammer is probably still
better than no war hammers blood bowl 2
will be out jun 2015 on pc ps4 and xbox
one
did you ring bother no Jim I didn't miss
the touchdown
you